look who's here on our set right now we
look at it on other than the NFL insider
on Fox Sports he's also the main
broadcaster and analyst from the
Bellator circuit right now and his
merging vets and players Organization
for transitioning members of the
military and the National Football
League vets and players org is the stuff
from heaven good to see you thank you
brother
o Glaser all right before we get into
all the the Glazer life and world of
Bellator and an MVP why we're real real
quick real quick last time I was on the
show yes I was wearing the Michael
Strahan suit and I think he promised you
a whole wardrobe did that out he sent me
some what do we call it athletic wear is
that what we are you wearing a beer yeah
I mean is so cheap but if it's free it's
it's me I'm fine with right this is yes
but straight Michael Michael Strahan
athletic wear
it's athleisure line I believe we call
these your loss great thing is that I
think the fact that I've come on the
show now yes I'm showing off Michael
Strahan yes clothes kind of makes me a
supermodel if you think about I would
totally agree with that assessment by
the way I would not deny you that status
whatsoever thank you and what straight
you know I understand if he doesn't send
me a suit he's he is the pick and change
out of the bushes if I make ends meet I
said he really is still picking change
on the couch cushion I'm sure yes yes so
let's get into this thing with Amari
Cooper yeah were you super I know that
you were talking about how broken weeks
ago that they were looking to train them
and then Jon Gruden came out and said
now I don't know where these reports are
coming from which is why I knew it was
true that I'm like I'm golden when you
get calls from coaches and general
managers saying that is false you think
that that is we didn't call me to tell
me was false he said to the media after
there was false that's it golden um were
you surprised though at the first round
selection so ever after
when these teams they were talking to in
the past so it's like a two plus two
plus a player or two plus but whatever
was and they were there was a lot of
throwers a lot of teams who were willing
to give up a to firms
once I the way kind of the game of
telephone goes in this league is once
you put a story out then teams don't
want to seem eager to that team so they
call middlemen if you will right because
they they call other people with
information because if they call that
team the Raiders then it seems like
they're too overeager and they could
jack the price up they call and you tell
everybody what you know what went down
that was originally for two plus and
then at the last second they changed it
for one Gordon wanted a one and I had
several team say for a two we do it for
two but when you have several humans who
say they're gonna do for two that means
in my mind okay somebody's gonna get
pushed into giving up a one with all it
takes is one it's all day and then
here's the thing I know is it steep Tom
will tell it's not steep if the guy ends
up making six Pro Bowls for them and
it's not steep for the Raiders
if the player they choose ends up being
better than among a coupe exactly eight
any time if there's a draft choice
related trade any time the draft is
involved you have to wait to see whether
it was worth it or not
yeah no question about it when the Jets
traded of an absurd amount of draft
choices just to move up to three with
the Indianapolis Colts this past year
and it sounded like a steep price to pay
but it winds up with them getting Sam
darn old then
well the Eagles of course from once
that's another one too right obviously
so we have to wait and see on that front
understood it does though smack a little
bit of desperation right now if you tell
us would you not agree on that yeah and
there was other receivers that were
we're being chopped to them so when you
give me some names um I think Benjamin
up and buff with one of the Benjamins
Kelvin Benjamin
[Laughter]
oh man who else the receiver Miami
Devante was Parker I think your stills
no no yeah so that's why I was kind of
being shopped to her obviously
tomorrow's Thomas's name is out there
but look I think this will end up being
the most active pre trade deadline we've
seen
long time and it's too full one the
Eagles wheeled and dealed their way to a
Super Bowl title last year and to the
colomac trade because people were really
in heavy on Khalil Mak with with really
high compensation and obviously turned
out well for the Bears crab beyond well
for the Bears so I think teams where
they might have been afraid to make the
teams in the past you feel like I'm not
gonna call it because then they're gonna
want too much teams this is a wheeling
and dealing market right now that's not
to say they'll be more trades than ever
before but we've already seen Carlos
side right then we had yesterday's trade
with Cooper I think we're gonna I know
for the GM's I too have talked to their
this week saying we're gonna call
everybody we're gonna burn up the phone
lines we're gonna see if there's
anything out there we can get Jay Glazer
here on the Rich Eisen show is Patrick
Peterson a real possibility to be moved
that's the game of telephone
so the Saints called or try to you know
called it the Cardinals for Peterson
them word of that leaked out the Saints
called but the game of telephone was
like it was the opposite like they were
then shopping him and Steve calms
absolutely not
got the kind of a great contract his
young player makes all these Pro Bowls
beloved here I'm trying to build this
franchise not traded away or tear it
down but it's almost like they didn't
want to hear what he had to say so
more and more teams started a calling I
mean there's people as division started
call its didn't eat her sin demand a
trade died so that then then obviously I
think he saw the writing and then he is
you know reportedly asked to be shopped
just could you asked out doesn't mean
that's gonna happen you know it's not
the NBA it's not like when your kid says
to me dauber talk to me again you don't
take them literally they tell you to go
clean your room you you you sit and
Renton and you know throw a tantrum you
still gonna clean your room well the
thing is is that Cooper obviously for
Dallas can take them from what they
currently have and make them a Super
Bowl contender I'm talking about the at
the high end of their expectations for
2018 making them a contender
because that defense is ready to get
some points on the board and they can
win some games with that defense in
Dallas Patrick Peterson can take a an
already Super Bowl contender
and put them on a podium picnic so
exactly so the number of people that
must be blown up Steve comms phone right
now I'm sure the Chiefs are doing it
well not only for him but they're also
calling about Chandler Jones
and Steve is gone why would I possibly
trade Chandler Jones because they've got
one win and they've got a rookie
quarterback hey that that's not winning
any football they still but they got
younger players who are star Patrick
Peterson Chandler Jones are not that old
word you're the wheels are not falling
off but I had one coach who called me
and it's it's like dealing with a bunch
of kindergarten today when you talk to
those Cardinals why is he not willing to
trade Patrick Peterson I'm like and I'm
telling him why he goes oh just come on
okay by the way great negotiation you
got it come on Jay Glazer here on the
show shefter tells me the same thing
Ian Rapoport to you guys and you know
information women as well Joe's inna
Anderson I'm sure I don't have any
conversations with her everybody who
does this men women who do this for a
living you are basically that you're
like a part information person you're
part psychologist information brokers
yes your psychosis your all right were
they were they bout that they they
bounce their troubles off of you but
they also maybe because they know you're
talking to the other side too and
they're filling you with with
information or disinformation I think
that there that might be for them for me
it's thank god I've been able to forge
my careers based on loyalty based on
relationships not based on scoops really
the scoops come with the relationships
and coming to loyalty so I don't get
snow balled as much as anybody else plus
I I threaten physical violence yeah I
like it
do you have something over there Chris
Brockman right in the middle of our
conversation with Glaser here oh yeah
right in the middle looks like the
Giants are trading Eli Apple to the
Saints do you have anything in your
Inbox on that no I do not everything on
my inbox about tap that's an interesting
one again I know Sean has been really
looking for a cornerback and there's a
prize money liable from though really
surprised it's why was that B I don't
know if I see those two guys fitting I'm
surprised by don't put all
I mean they have been looking for help
at that position again they're gone for
Patrick Peterson there they were looking
but when Shawn and I were talking last
week we're just kind of going over names
and he was like even starters it's it's
hard to find sure we could but I think
that's the type of guy also deal at work
he has not had success in New York did
not mess with his teammates in they're
not messing that locker room and a lot
of the good coaches are like hey I could
I could I should turn them into that
first round I'll take a look at New
England I mean Josh Gordon already just
a few weeks you know you're a brewer
people from bottom off the field you
don't have any issues apparently that
we're finding out about but they
obviously could put velvet ropes around
any situation and keep you out of the
club and also I mean he's he's improving
in a way and that was just a fifth round
selection which is why again I guess to
bring it full circle with Amari Cooper
that's so so expensive and as I tweeted
out that if Amari Cooper is worth the 1
Patrick Peterson probably is right and
require a Powerball to require him and
and the Saints don't have a first round
selection next year so maybe the Eli
Apple move makes sense because they
don't have the current fire power right
now draft wise to go get somebody like
Peterson do you think the Chiefs are on
this market yeah I think they're gonna
be aggressive also in this you know they
were in it with with Earl Thomas you
know I think they're gonna be aggressive
here because they know that obviously
their defensive sports but I think
they're gonna be looking for playmakers
anywhere on that defense so what do you
think's going on with the Jaguars and
and that's a because I'm calling their
game this week it'll be fascinating they
already said Blake bortles is the guy
that was announced when we went off the
air as well after last yesterday's show
and is it possible Eli Manning goes
there is it possible at all anything's
possible
I think Eli shell-shocked before what
happened last year in New York but what
Jacksonville Jaguars are built not to be
not to have a quarterback karyam they're
built to have that running game carry
him and once for a net went down and not
just for a net that whole backfields has
been banged up and banged up that's how
they're they're built like an old one of
the old NFC East teams and one of the
old Tom Coughlin teams as in back in the
80s with parts
that's how they're built they're built
in a really ferocious defense and
running in that will just gut you and
gas you and gut you and gas you and they
haven't had that so as a result it
exposes portals so do you think they'd
be interested in getting Eli Manning I
think that they would certainly be
interested in upgrading at the
quarterback position because right now
they have two guys that you know for
them to pull portals in that situation
you know is shows that okay we're he's
not your endo sail well I mean Jalen
Ramsey said we all know what's going on
here I just can't say it right how much
there's no other options there right now
but again you could hide it when you
have a really strong running there are
options there's always options you can
again I don't know if Eli is the proper
fit to go to Jacksonville just cuz
confident I'm calling for Derek Carr to
or from any of this what he's about to
say cuz absolutely the calls are coming
from within the house in Oakland right
now I mean Khalil max GaN Cooper's gone
the winches are they're crazy if they
want to get rid of my opinion it's so
hard to find a quarterback in this
league tarot cards already proven that
he can play through pain will play
through injuries it can be a playoff
caliber quarterback we saw it a couple
of years ago with the right coaching
system so you know that uh Derek Carr
has been tweeting his head off this
morning you know you write for the
athletic your mailbag is on there right
now there's on their own exactly and
we'll talk about that in a second but
one of your colleagues on the Athletic
says that that he's lost the locker room
yeah partially because he was seen on
film crying when he was tight when he
was her Ivan again I don't have I'm not
good questions from Yeltsin reporting of
course especially on my teams all right
oh my god again I have no idea cuz he
tweeted out this morning in response to
you know his brother Darren yeah there's
so many cars basically was tweeting
about that story today and he responded
to pro football talk as well which
picked up the athletic story don't even
waste your time with this big bro on the
ground I yelled to get me up get me then
I got to the sidelines and yelled again
not one tear not one time there is the
truth people will click on it because it
sounds crazy but stop playing with me
and Derek was responding again to his
brother Darren
putting on Twitter all the injuries I'd
sit again yet another one also that's
pretty straight yeah another one saying
that I'm a Raider in that script but
that's great you know I'm a Raider it's
not a popular thing to be a Raider right
now but I am and I love it you know and
we've got the tweet on the screen right
now and folks can go to Derek Carr QB
right now to see all of his tweets but I
saw this the writing on the wall once
Khalil Mack was gone that if if if
through just one month of the season
Gruden doesn't like Derek Carr yeah
that's gonna be the awkward moment when
he goes to mark Davis and says hey Mark
you know I know I'm on the hook for with
you for 90 more million bucks so this is
what I'm thinking
try and stop me I'm sure he wouldn't say
it that way but that's the leverage that
these the conversations have but hey
Mark guess what that quarterback who
took up so much of our cap so we
couldn't pay coach so we had to trade
him I don't want that quarterback now -
yeah I don't really get what we're just
coming is there isn't that coming
with no thing I can't predict anything
that John's can do because it's so far
even like a Kalu Mack Callooh
really didn't have any leverage except
to say no I don't want to play for you
so that was it and Gruden's like he want
to come here he's out like I said before
it's like when your kid tells you don't
ever talk to me again
it's like John took him seriously okay I
want to talk to you again no you know
here's the suitcase that's the frontal
column coming up in and they cut they
cut negotiations out so the Raiders gave
an offer Matt came back with an offer
and then the Raider said it's it all
talks are off like that
it's ago she ations that's it it's not a
you don't have a first
take-it-or-leave-it offer it's not what
happens and then you realized how
miserable life could be without a pass
rusher and what's happening with levy on
bail before we put a ribbon on this ol
levy on it was fun Fox NFL Sunday this
week Herman if he asked me the question
it was going on Le'Veon Bell and I said
Kurt you know when Levien's coming in he
said no Jay when I said no I'm asking
you do you know what he's coming because
nobody knows every time we see a report
he's gonna show up a certain time it
doesn't happen what I can tell you that
a report of this on Fox on Sunday and
the two sides finally had discussions
last week but it's discussion where is
the Raiders they're you know they want a
two week roster exam
you mean the dealers to steal the star
experience yep it's all good dealers I
mean that a lot
the Steelers have a two-week roster
exemption and don't want to pay him
don't have to pay him for that - across
their exemption
Le'Veon Bell has to sign off on that
before he comes in in size his franchise
tender they can't really get going until
they agree to terms on this two-week
period now that's not to say that they
can turn around after two days ago
okay we're putting you in the office
active roster Oh pea but right now they
don't want to pay him for these two
weeks they so he so does their heels in
so deep so just again so for everyone to
understand out there so he has to come
in by week 11 in order to be the free
agent now it's to be no he does not know
he 30 he's already accrued enough
seasons okay so he doesn't have to play
at all this year no when I understand
here's enough to go so I think that was
I may be wrong I know I'm just
explaining the other day he already has
enough seasonal walk all right so let's
just say so in other words he wants to
come in and play but the Steelers if
let's just say levy on bail says I want
to come in and play yes they will
basically say you have pissed us off so
much we're gonna just set you for two
weeks if they chew Harriett right it
won't be any oil James Connors plane is
that route for they may not but even
when he does come back in there yeah I
don't think the players never wanted to
just be handed over taking away from
James Conner either this has been best
reality show has it's been off the
charts but also this morning Chad Kelly
was arrested in Denver yeah for a
criminal trespassing at 1:15 a.m. this
morning go ahead and ask the Polk
question of glaze before we take a break
which NFL team glaze is in the most
disarray Cardinals Cowboys Giants
Raiders Raiders you didn't stutter
absolutely how are they in disarray if
Gruden's acquiring all these first four
he's got three first-round draft choices
right now and this is all based on him
seeing the roster and saying this is not
what I want I want to get rid of them
all he's got he's clearing a bunch of
money hmm
off the books he is burning it down to
the ground and starting to build it up
in the name and face of Gruden well it's
just red because
see there's disconnect between him and
his general manager that's bad it's just
right because you got rid of one of the
best pass rushers in the NFL and then
openly complain that you can't find pass
rushers in this league and the reason
why they got rid of the pass rushers cuz
they didn't want to pay right and the
reason why they couldn't pay him is
because there's a quarterback taking a
not true I don't know ways to do things
man there's wasted there's ways to
manipulate the cap to do a lot in this
league
what's the current poll results right
now 41% Raiders 37% Giants see here's
the thing with the Giants when people
don't got to remember is there's a
reason why they had the second pick in
the draft last year they were a mess and
they thought okay we're bringing a left
tackle we draft a good left card and we
got safe on Berkeley a new coach all our
problems are gonna be erased that's not
it they got to rebuild that locker room
the energy in that locker room they got
a ways to go
any time Belichick let somebody go you
got to wonder why yep cuz solder just
keys he is no but sometimes he thinks
also like the Chandler Jones he thinks
all my system - yeah that's true - it's
not always the case
hey Cruz Chandler Jones check out the
glaze right now on the athletic comm and
we read it all the time right now Jay
Glaser's mailbag is on the athletic
right now and you can go there check out
him check out all of the great sports
writing ken Rosenthal Seth Davis is
there as well
there are no pop-up ads it's all about
the content and the best part about this
is the athletic comm / rich eyes and go
there right now and subscribe you get
40% off your first year subscription we
all love the at the athletic so does
glaze subscribe today the athletic comm
/ Rich Eisen where we're back with a
little bit more national football league
information and we'll talk about this
incredible organization that Jay Glazer
has built and is flourishing to help all
the folks out there who may know
somebody in the member of the military
that needs some help transitioning from
the world of the military to the
civilian life Jay Glazer more on that in
a moment thank you my friend Jay Glazer
spending a little bit more time with him
right here let's talk about merging vets
and players org and again this is an
organ
where you saw football players have a
tough time transitioning after their
careers and obviously members of the
military with whom your friends yeah
having trouble transitioning to civilian
life as well so we're just trying to you
know put these two groups together and
we're trying to really it's more it's
more of a mental health group than
anything else and you know like I said
earlier you playing in the NFL when that
uniform comes off your value should not
go away what's behind your rib cage they
got you to beat out millions of people
to play in the NFL
that's who you argue that you got to use
that in your next step and our military
brothers and sisters same thing like I'm
trying to really get them to be proud of
their scars to be proud of everything
they've done other over there because
that's that's really our only choice and
I'll give you a couple stories here and
look we're in the so we'll work out for
like a half hour just kind of get that
burn again and just so you can kind of
help out your brother and your sister
and get that team going again and then
afterwards we sit around and we talk
about suicide why you shouldn't kill
yourself there's 22 vets a day that kill
themselves it's not okay it's becoming
an epidemic not just in the veterans
society but elsewhere because they see
others do it's almost a power suggestion
it's you know it's okay to feel off it's
okay to have mental health issues it's
okay to like I I'm very messed up and
I'm good with it and I want everybody
else do too you know do the same thing
um we're in our group couple weeks ago
and we have one of our vets who says hey
I got something guys and we all talk
around afternoon we surround and talk he
said there's a player this week and
Everson Griffin that went off the
reservation it's on us it's on our group
right here these vets it's on us to
really educate the world on it's not a
stigma it doesn't have to be a bad thing
you've got to we've got to help people
really understand mental health because
people don't understand it in the back
of the room a hand raises he says guys
my name is Rick Spillman I'm the GM of
the Vikings he happened to be there
because they were playing the Rams and
he said that player is my player you're
right we don't really know how to deal
with this well so I appreciate all your
guys helping this like you get these
veterans around they the smartest group
of individuals I have the
kula support group on the planet and
it's my job I got a big mouth it's my
job to get them to understand how
brilliant they are and and look last
week we had one in New York and Roger
Goodell came for two hours and he's out
there and we had well we had some badass
Obie's in that room and you know as you
saw Chad cascading sit there saying he
his season his career ended and he had
he's looking for that locker room and he
finally found it in this and that's what
we're trying to do but we have a guy in
there and Denver more semanas unit
they've lost I think 72 brothers now in
battle and suicide 72 and my think to
them and with Commissioner Wright eras
as bad as that is you have to know in
yourself
you have withstood losing 72-year
brothers there is something special
about you there's something different
about you I don't know if I could do
that I don't know if I can handle that
but you need to see how strong you
really are what kind of heroes all you
guys are you've got to be proud of your
scars man because it's our only choice
and you know I personally I have no I
said grand illusions or I go for grand
goals I am gonna personally do whatever
I can I think I can make a dent in this
suicide epidemic I may not be able to
but I'm gonna die trying to do it man
I'm gonna do whatever I can to make this
dent with my new team of these vets and
players I'm I'm so proud of this crew
well I'm proud of you man you say he's
got a big mouth you got your hearts
bigger I appreciate it vets and players
org for people to find out about the MVP
near you and how you can donate and keep
this going now on a go nationwide in the
40 seconds I've got left you got the
forum on Saturday the Saturday before
the Superbowl it seems of Super Bowl
week Bellator right we're having our
Heavyweight Grand Prix finals here Ryan
Bader is fight in favor of melon Danko
Ryan Bader was actually the first guy we
ever trained players with was with Jared
Allen way back in the day now here is
fighting for the every weight
championship of the world it's after the
forum Saturday January 26th and Bellator
you know again thanks to them
empowerment Network who has been helping
us open up these other MVP locations
around the country it's a really good
team we got man Huston in Miami's a
Thursday night football game my socks
you're part of the pre in
and the post great to see you jigglin I
appreciate brother thank you mess please
come back and it's absolutely no you
will some more threads and I'll bring in
your denim Jack berry good the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience